- You're delusional.
Let's start there.
- [Narrator] You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- Welcome to another episode
of Perfectly Mentored.
I'm your host Jason Portnoy.
My guest today is
actually, if you don't
know who this man is,
an introduction is not gonna do anything.
You've been living under a rock.
You don't know who this guy is,
something's wrong 'cause he's everywhere.
The man, the myth, the legend,
Gary Vaynerchuk, welcome to the show.
- Thanks of having me brother.
- He's also the reason, by the way,
that we're here right now
and doing this today.
He was the man who told me,
start a podcast
and if I do a certain amount of episodes
he'd be on.
So true to his word,
so happy to have you on.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
I'm proud of your bro.
- You always the same questions,
your answers are usually the same,
which is a good thing,
it means you're staying consistent,
but I'm wondering,
how many of these questions are just
self-validation questions, - A lot.
where they already know the answer to it.
- A lot, a lot.
- Does that trouble you at all?
- No, I'm, I don't
think when you're trying
to provide value that you get to decide
what the value is.
That's actually giving.
See people don't get it.
Like, "Gary, you're full of yourself."
Look a little bit deeper,
like, I have no ambition
to dictate the value that I provide.
I have ambition of providing the value
the person wants.
So if somebody want to roll up
and they need four minutes of my time
while I'm running to my next meeting
and I'm busy,
but because nothing gets me more hyped
than like bring humans value,
that they need validation,
even though I know 92% of the time
that's literally what's gonna
happen in this micro-moment,
I'm thrilled to do it
because then if they go fuckin' do it,
they start a podcast
and get an interview with me.
- Awesome.
But then it goes to the
next level too, right?
You go to all these conferences,
I was just at a conference
where people are talking' 'bout
game changing, life changing conference
and then people come home
and I question how many
people three months later
have their lives changed.
It goes back to the feeling of
people like listen to your
content and consume it,
they like the feeling of being motivated,
but then there's work that
has to be done after it
and I don't think people
like that feeling.
- Yeah and I think that's why I talk about
tryin' to find things you like,
not making money the
variable of happiness.
Like, you know, I genuinely believe,
I really do that long term,
I will be far more
validated because I
just really, really know
that what I'm speaking about is just
tried and true human behavior
with an understanding of modern day
contextual technology advancements, right?
So things are exaberated, like,
and things of that nature.
So, yeah, I mean, yes.
You know this.
I make content
that literally says stop
watching me, go do it,
and then they go watch somebody else
that charges them for the information.
So like, yeah, people like
consuming motivational content
'cause they think they're
actually doing something.
I think it's like watching
somebody else work out.
- It's a good point.
- And so, I'm hoping that,
but this is why I like to talk my truth.
It's the 97th time somebody saw...
Like, the amount of people that have hit,
this is why reading every content matters.
Do you know motivating it
is when you read a comment
that says, "Gary V. I
watched you for four months.
"I loved you,
"then I thought you were a dick face.
"I didn't watch you.
"But now I'm back
"and now I've been watchin'
you for a year and a half
"and just yesterday,
"that post, with you in the barn,
"is the reason now I did it."
and I'm like, fuck.
The thing I did in the barn
I've done 874 times,
just not in the barn,
and not with that word
and not with that mean title,
and it was this time,
after 17 months,
four months of which they
thought I was douchebag,
that it was piece of content
that actually got them to
actually go to the gym and work out?
I'm into it.
- So is it flattering is someone's like
- Yes. - I can't listen to Gary anymore,
he just says the same thing over and over,
he's repetitive.
- Flattering.
Yeah, why in the world
would I make up shit
to like entertain you
on fuckin' Instagram?
I will never be historically incorrect
at the moment I said it.
I will never say anything
I don't believe in.
I will never say it.
I don't need the likes.
I don't need the money.
I don't need the admiration,
which is what I really like,
I don't need any of that to say something
I don't believe in.
- Got it.
So, another thing that
you are very clear on
is hustling, working hard,
a hard work ethic.
- I think hard work matters.
- I agree with you,
but there's this whole wave,
I don't know if you've seen,
of people coming in now...
- Are you kidding?
I'm the one whose fucking...
- Work life balance,
that you shouldn't work hard...
- Of course.
I'm the one that gets picked on for that
because the manifestation
of me believing in hard work
has been, you know,
I say that I sleep six,
seven, eight hours,
and that nobody should do anything
that doesn't make them happy,
and that making $47,000
a year and being happy
is amazing,
and yet people wanna
make me the poster child
of overworking and burning yourself out.
I get it,
I understand what happens
once you hit a certain tier,
I also understand that
maybe I could have done
a better job
earlier in the process of my career
in creating clarification,
thus I'm okay with getting link bated into
some of these conversations
but, listen, I believe
in work-life balance.
I just think my work-life
balance is different than yours.
I also think that happiness
needs to be thought about.
And like, when you love what you do,
this is my hobby.
- You also have to know
what you want, right?
- Correct.
- If you wanna be a billionaire,
you're not gonna do it
by just sleeping all day.
- And by the way,
let me say one more time,
'cause I've got to clarify
it all the fuckin' time,
I'll say it for the 9,000th fuckin' time,
the pursuit of trying
to buy he New York Jets
is my passion
'cause it allows me to
play the game that I love
I love being a businessman
the way a lot of you
love playing football,
the way a lot of you love to ski,
the way a lot of you love to read,
the way a lot of you love to cook,
watch Netflix,
hang out with your friends.
If, given the option,
besides garage selling and
watching the Jets professionally,
forget about family,
that's on a pedestal
that nothing can touch,
outside of spending time
with my inner family
and closest friends,
and outside of garage selling
and watching the Jets,
there's nothing I'd rather do
that work a 15 hour day.
- You're self aware.
You know you.
- And I always have.
This is why iI shoveled snow,
and did lemonade.
I washed fuckin' cars as a seven year old
all day long on August 9th,
'cause it's what I like
and I'm not gonna judge
somebody who wants to work
nine to five,
be on 13 fuckin' softball teams,
and play fuckin' video games all day,
and make 42K a year,
if she and he are pumped as fuck,
they're equal to me
because I know a bunch of
miserable fuckin' billionaires
and I know a lot of fuckin'
happy 55K a yearers,
and everything in between.
So, here's my thing,
if you listen carefully,
I'm only spinning two core things:
you be self-aware
and you make yourself happy
and don't let anything other variables,
you adjust to macro variables
and two, this is what makes me happy.
Lot of people are spinning their ideology
on other people,
especially after they've
already accomplished something.
- So you talk patience, too, right?
That people should be patient
in the pursuit of their goals.
At what point does patience
just become delusion?
- A lot of times.
- So, what are the hacks
or the tips that you,
for them to be self aware
to know when to just,
when is patience just run it's course.
- If you've been doing the
same thing for seven years
and nothing good has happened,
you're delusional.
Let's start there.
That's a test.
I believe in that.
If there's been no
progress in your rap career
or in your art
or video blog
and you've been doing it
every day for seven years,
as hard as you can,
and nothing has happened,
the market has spoken.
That's one way.
Now, is that four years,
is that two years,
do people jump off?
You need to see some level of progress
to keep you having blood in
the water to get you going,
but sometimes there is a breakthrough
because if the machine is in
between you and the market,
when the you gotta be discovered.
But the reason now I think it's more pure,
is 'cause SoundCloud, and Spotify,
and YouTube, and Shopify,
and Amazon,
now you get the feedback loop so fast
and it isn't the
arbitrary, subjective call,
the reason it took some
of the greatest stars
of all time 11 years to break though
is 'cause other people had say.
People didn't see Gaga's talent,
they thought she was weird.
Somebody thought she wasn't weird,
she breaks out.
But Lady Gaga today,
she goes on fuckin' YouTube
and fucking Spotify direct
and the market speaks quicker.
People are more famous quicker now
if they have the talent,
'cause nobody's in the middle.
This is why I talk in general terms
on content, of course,
'cause I don't have the context,
but if somebody sat here
and I listened for 40 minutes
I would tell them if they're delusional
or just impatient.
And most people are
impatient and delusional.
I mean, that's just the reality of it.
- You speak to a lot of
young, startup entrepreneurs,
that you get approached
all the time for advice,
but here at Vayner you work
with a lot of big companies,
what can some of the
young entrepreneurs learn
from the big companies
and what can big companies learn from
the young entrepreneurs?
- That's a great question.
And honestly, I would argue
that that is a core strength of mine,
that I play in both worlds
and so I'm able to see the common themes.
I think big companies can learn that
process for the sake of process
is the worst think of all time
and that's all they've become.
And that longterm marathon running
and building a business is better
than every 90 days,
but they're stuck 'cause
they pander to Wall Street.
I think startups are impatient,
underestimate scale,
pander to VCs,
big companies pander to Wall Street,
startups pander to VCs,
neither panders to the end consumer.
I genuinely believe that because I pander
to the end consumer, the audience,
that I am who I am.
Why y-library was what
y-library what it was;
the intermedia is,
everybody panders to things in the middle
that mean nothing.
- How important is intention
when you're doing all this?
- The most.
If I'm, if this interview
is not heard by anybody,
it's not a great use of time other than
sharpening your craft, right?
Which is not horrible.
But like, it's better if it get heard
and the reason I film everything is
Dustin's gonna watch this
and he's gonna take a clip
and if one of 'em achieves
1.5 million in views
on Instagram at the moment of scale,
that's a good day because
we've created more awareness.
- A then a good podcast number too.
- That's right.
- So if attention matters
what's going on in the
marketing industry right now?
There's a lot of pollution,
a lot of bottom feeders coming out,
you know, I do paid media
for a lot of clients
and they're preaching that whole
"Spend a dollar, make 10 dollars"
and clients are staring to think that
they need to see a ten...
- You're talking about row ads?
- Yeah. All clients are
now sitting there saying,
"Oh, a dollar should make 10 dollars",
- That's crazy.
- but it's crazy for me when
I run ads like for myself,
one x is great because if
I'm getting my money back
and my marketing content
is still out there,
and I'm still building a brand,
that's amazing.
How do we clean up the marketing industry
and reset the expectations
our clients have?
- Letting the market
do what it always does.
Do you know that
everybody that picks on me
for telling people that you
don't need to make a lot,
there are literally
people now pushing back
on my thesis that you can be happy without
making a lot of money.
This is literally now happening.
Like watching it.
This is remarkable.
Let me explain how I
plan on addressing that.
By not addressing it until
the economy collapses
and then making some comments on
how historically correct I was.
- So the market will course correct
and take away all the bottom feeders.
- And your control in the scenario is
when a client says to you, "No bro.
"I need $10 row ads."
you're like thank you very much,
I'm not the guy for you.
- Yeah. That's what I said.
- Great, me too.
- And when the guy's
post that they can get
ten X offer to hire them
and then they disappear.
- Funny how that works.
- If you could speak to every
entrepreneur in the world,
you're on...
- I'm planning on it.
- Well, with this podcast.
- Yes, of course.
- If you're standing on top of a mountain
and you could have the attention of
every single entrepreneur in the world,
what would you tell them?
- Real entrepreneurs or
people that are claiming
to be entrepreneurs during this era?
- Real, hard working entrepreneurs.
- How lucky did we get that we
didn't end up being athletes.
- Why is that?
- 'cause they have to retire at 36.
- I mean, you just brought up
something really, really good.
You work with a lot of athletes.
I'm just curious from your mindset,
I asked Fran Arsana the same question,
what are some of the
common characteristics
between the most successful athletes
and the most successful
business people you've met?
- Preparation.
Competitiveness.
Deep passion for the fuckin' game.
I mean that's a real entrepreneur.
She or he loves it so much
they couldn't be, I mean,
my actions have spoken long before
entrepreneurship was cool.
I was not capable of being a student
'cause of my deep passion
for entrepreneurship.
It was baseball cards,
it was baseball cards that didn't allow me
to be a good student.
I was incapable of sitting in class
and not dreaming about
selling Bo Jackson cards.
It took me over.
But for some reason,
when you're an athlete,
and you're missing a bunch of school
because you're a great athlete,
or when your Beyonce being
home-schooled, right?
That makes sense.
But not for entrepreneurs, right?
It doesn't seem like you're allowed
to miss a ton of...
If you're an unbelievable actor, actress,
singer, athlete,
missing normal school is
something that all of us
in this room and listening
right now understand.
You're like, "Oh yeah.
That's what happens."
Like you're the best
quarterback in the world,
yeah, you gotta throw
with the quarterback,
and you miss first class, you know,
but not for entrepreneurs.
But that's who I was.
I used to baseball card shows,
baseball card shows in Jersey in the 90's
were Thursday to Sunday.
So you'd pay for a table
for Thursday to Sunday.
But I had to start Friday
afternoon after school,
I have to overpay for my tables
and try to make back my nut
on Friday afternoon, Saturday and Sunday.
- I'm curious to hear...
- I shoulda missed school on Thursday.
- I'm curious to hear what
your answer woulda been.
Let's say you're standing
on top of the mountain
talkin' to fake wannabe entrepreneurs.
- I would say, hey, gals and guys,
you're about to deal with a
very difficult scarlet letter.
You live as a entrepreneur
wannabe in 2019,
which means your propaganda
on your Instagram account
is painting a life.
Soon than later the economy will collapse.
You will then have to go work at
Chase Bank or
at somewhere else
and you're going to
have to stop showing the
facade of being a success entrepreneur
and so the sooner you could
start tellin' the truth
of actually being an entrepreneur
in the process of trying to win,
versus what...
Entrepreneurship got cool.
Super fun for me.
Rappers, sneakers,
it's been amazing.
I'm super happy.
I'm also unbelievably prepared
for it to be demonized
the way big banks were in 2008,
when the shit hits the fan,
and prepared for all the comments
that, "You Gary,
"you fucked my up.
"You told me entrepreneurship,
"now I'm this."
Really? 'casuse you didn't listen.
- But you make it look easy, right?
I don't watch LeBron play
and say, "Oh, I can be
"a basketball player." Right?
I watch business people, and your like...
- But you're not watching.
LeBron, you actually see it
and you don't actually see it,
because you just see
the byproduct at night.
LeBron's fucking in the
weight room right now.
LeBron's in...,
LeBron's eating healthy as fuck.
LeBron's watching film
on Ben Simmons right now.
You don't see that.
I'm in fucking meetings 17 hours a day
and my attempt to blog
everything really doesn't work
because there's so much
sensitive information,
but lately I've had a
couple of these mega-blogs,
right? Blogs,
where people are seeing my whole day
and these are fuckin' four to
seven hour videos on YouTube
and people are fucking goin' crazy.
Why, I'm realizing.
Like who the fuck would
wants to watch seven hours...
I mean I'm humbled,
but I realize is
now they're actually startin'
to see certain things.
Like oh, "That's how he treats people?
"Fuck.
"If he's don' that
"and he's nice to everybody,
"and I think I'm somebody
"'cause I have 4,000
followers on Instagram,
"maybe I'm doin' this wrong."
And so, yeah man,
when it really gets to the Truman Show
and people realize when
somebody a little bit braver
than me shows every single thing.
Like if I was just,
if I didn't have a company
with clients and employees,
I'd show everything, just not.
But I kinda sometimes dream of it
because that's what been
great about these mega-blogs.
Then you would really see it
and then it wouldn't seem so easy.
You go read the comments
on the four episodes
I put up that are long,
they're like, "Fuck.
That looks exhausting.
"How the fuck does he have
energy to say what's up
"and answer the same fuckin' thing."
Have you watched on of 'em"
- No.
- Have you?
So what's your hot take on it?
- [Cameraman] I mean, I
just can't believe you like,
saying yes to the selfies
over and over and over.
- And the patience.
And the attention.
And the sheer energy it takes
when you have attention.
- Yeah, but I mean, so you probably get
this push back a lot.
Easy for Gary to say, right?
He's made it.
He's there.
Easy for Gary to say.
I'll do that to if I get paid
millions of dollars a year.
- I hear way worse.
I hear fake manipulations of my story,
just one more time,
'cause we're having an on the record day,
I walked into my dad's business
doing 3.8 million dollars in sales,
grew it to a 60 million dollar business...
- So you weren't handed it
like some other people say.
- Of course not.
I left the 34 years...
Guys. If I was handed a 60
million dollar business,
why would I start VaynerMedia
in the conference room of Buddy Media
'cause I didn't have
enough money for rent.
No. What I did, unlike all you fuckers,
was I gave the 12 best years
of my life to my parents,
who I love the most,
built them a 60 million dollar business
and walked the 34 with no fuckin' money.
Now what?
Now what dick?
So, yes. People say,
"Easy for you to say."
And, by the way, it's what everybody does.
And, by the way, cool. Fine.
Easy because I have talent.
That I'll respect.
But I put in the work.
Like, you know what else is easy?
Being attractive.
You know how amazing it is
if you're born beautiful?
Boy or girl?
It's, let me save people time.
Where I'm white privileged now,
where I'm rich,
it's gonna come to beautiful
because people are starting to get deep
on like, their thinking.
One the the great things
to happen in your life
is to be a fucking smoke show.
I fucking male fucking model.
Gorgeous and fuck.
- Oh, I always say...
- You know. You lived it.
- I always said,
if I could come back in
life as a hot woman...
- Yes.
- ...knowing the market 'cause I have...
- By the way, by the way.
Just so everybody understands
so they're not confused,
if your are highly,
I'm talkin' like a 10
male or female,
your life is much better.
Door open that never could have opened.
- It's like some...
- Dustin, you getting invited to go to
Ibiza for a week,
all expense paid,
everything takin' care of shopping sprees?
- He was invited to a fire festival.
- Exactly.
So, like, there's a ton...
Here's my thing,
I'm just no judgin' anybody.
You know what I think
is a better advantage
than fuckin' being born into something?
Being born into nothing.
I'm on the record.
Remember I said it.
Can't wait to watch it in 20 years.
The internet, the way it is today,
I'd rather have zero than 100 million.
People that have zero are like,
"This fucking guy's an idiot."
that's 'cause you don't
talk to trust fund babies.
I do.
I talk to trust fund babies.
They damn me.
I meet them in real life
because of my business career.
They're fuckin' sad.
Do you know,
do you what it's like
to talk to a human being
that looks at you at
22 years old and says,
"No matter what I do,
"no matter what I do,
"for the next 80 years,
"it will never be my own accomplishment.
"Everybody will always say I was handed it
"and I'm done."
Do you know what kind
of level of depression,
cocaine and partying until
you die that leads to?
A lot.
- Both sides are always
always gonna come...
- 100%.
Any by the way,
nor do I expect anybody
that grew up the way I did,
in a studio apartment in Queens,
to have sadness for Richard Thompson III,
they will say what I always hear,
"Cool. I'll cry in Ferrari".
That's 'cause you don't
know what crying is dick.
Because smiling in your fucking Toyota
is way better than crying in your Ferrari.
But you can stay confused.
And when you get there,
whyncha call good ole Gary
and tell me how it actually feels.
Crying is never acceptable.
Not interesting
AKA, being sad and
depressed and not happy.
People are fucking confused.
If you think a fucking Ferrari,
or some fucking hot supremes,
or fucking pretty girl or boy,
or a yacht is gonna make you happy,
you're just not smart about life.
You go do you.
Everybody's should do
whatever the fuck they want.
I'm one person.
I do not...
On the record,
I'm in an on the record kinda mood today,
I genuinely do not believe
that my points of view
are more valuable than
anybody else's I've ever met.
I genuinely feel that way.
I genuinely do.
Do I subconsciously
understand that my thoughts
on business probably,
since I've been doing
it every day of my life
for the last fuckin' 37 years,
carry some weight more than somebody
whose drawn every day for 37 years?
Probably.
But maybe they're just a natural talent
and they see it differently.
Like I don't get high on my supply.
I enjoy sharing.
I enjoy admiration.
I enjoy content.
I enjoy humans tremendously.
But, I'm gonna die
and nobody's gonna,
like, I'm gonna have a day,
I feel like at this point,
like I'm feelin' confident
that I'm gonna have good,
like, I definitely feel
like people are gonna
share their favorite memories,
I feel like I'll have a little bit of.
I'll have a day,
half a day,
like I'll trend for a few minutes.
- It's gonna be a tough speaking
gig at your funeral, eh?
- Yeah. I don't know who wants that.
You know, but like,
I genuinely think like,
and then what, right?
Prince died.
Fuckin', you know like.
Michael Jackson died.
These people make global fuckin' impact,
you know what I mean?
So, like,
but I don't care what anybody thinks
and nor do I think my value on anybody,
my opinion on anybody matters.
I do have a yearning to communicate.
And so I'll do that.
You're more than welcome to listen or not.
- I wanna to let you
end with just a pitch.
Talk about Empathy Wines
and why that started it
and to into that.
- I appreciate that.
It's very kind.
I grew up in the wine business.
I'm very fascinated by direct
to consumer wine, brands.
I knew I had a ton of
leverage with farmers.
I just knew that I could
make a $40 - $60 wine
for 20 bucks,
and I was curious of
what kind of side hustle
that would look like
and most importantly,
John Trowman and me, Schroeder,
have been with me for decades,
admins, interns,
came all the way up the system,
and I felt like it was time
to take a swing with them as my partners.
So, I get to put kids on,
that the Dustins and the Seths
who are sitting here right now,
could be like, I assume,
I don't wanna speak for them,
but like, it's probably cool to be like,
knowing you're coming
in on the ground floor,
you're hustling, grinding, working,
we work hard,
but when you get to look at those guys
and be like, "they own a winery?
"Well, maybe I can?"
It's always good to see,
that's why it's so powerful
to see something, right?
It's powerful to see, for me,
I'm sure as a kid, I don't remember,
seeing immigrants from
the old country make it.
It's powerful to see somebody
from the hood make it.
It's powerful to see a woman...
...that's why I love
amplifying stories of like
all different shapes and sizes,
'cause all you need to
do is see one, right?
So, it's great.
It makes me happy.
If feels like all that...
You know I ask of my people
that are in my most inner circle
to work hard,
to not, you know,
you can work in VeynerMedia
and get paid more,
you're more than welcome,
but there's somethin' really
rad if you're willin' ta...
I'm askin' them to do what I did.
I was 34 years old.
There's not a lot of people on earth
that have ever built
something as quickly as I did.
On earth.
There's plenty that built way bigger.
But if you take them, 7.7
billion fuckin' people,
the amount that have takin' something
and grown it in seven years the way I did,
for somebody else,
gets real small real fast.
- Look, out of all the things
that you've accomplished
and there's a lot that people
admire you for, I think,
being this is my second
time of VeynerMedia,
the one thing that I can
tell you as a business owner,
that's the most impressive out of it all,
is the culture you built here
of the people that will go all in for you,
and that's just incredible.
- And that only comes in one way.
There is no fucking drinking Kool-Aid.
You don't trick humans.
You could trick 'em for a few minutes,
but not sustained...at scale.
Like people...
Kool-Aid.
Snake oil salesman.
I read these comments...
How do you not understand
what 20 fuckin' years
of sustained growth means?
- At 21, there's very few
people I would stay 'til
8PM, 9PM to go work for.
Yet the fact that you have
an entire office of people
that's just willing just
give you their nights,
give you their weekends,
impressive.
- And the fuckin' hundreds
and hundreds of thousands
behind it that are tryin' to get in.
Right?
People are like, "They work so hard."
This isn't Soviet Russia.
And you know what the best part is,
and Seth probably knows better,
but that's because he's
been a quick learner,
I also put them on
when they don't want
to be be here anymore.
To me, it's not like,
you know, it'd be,
it'd be one thing if
Seth's like, "You know,
"I'm gonna go work at Audible."
I'm like, go fuck yourself.
I wold literally e-mail
the fucking CEO of Audible,
first, I'd be like dick,
why didn't you talk to me,
I woulda got you a better,
I woulda got you more money at Audible.
That woulda been the first reaction.
Second, I woulda fuckin',
like the next thing I do,
like, there's a way to live life.
I understand what it looks like
and it's very basic.
People have made shit really complicated.
When you're fulfilled,
you can start giving.
So I'm fulfilled, emotionally, right.
The end.
So I'm capable to give
and there are people out
there that are that way
and I'm thankful that I'm one of them.
One thing that I'm concerned about is,
as I get bigger,
people using me to make themselves bigger.
The counter to my message
is money makes you happy.
And peole are gonna fall for it.
- Look I use you as fuel.
When I first met you
and I said how would you build an agency,
'causee I'm building an agency,
and Gary seriously looked
me in the eyes and said,
"I wouldn't.
"I wouldn't build an agency."
I'm like Hm.
Okay.
Well there goes that, that's deflated.
And then I went home and I'm like,
and it took me a couple of days,
like my wife, my friends they're
all like, "What's wrong?"
I'm like, well that was just deflating.
And they're like, "You're letting one guy
"dictate what you're gonna do?
"Snap out of it."
- The same way
- "He doesn't know you.
"He doesn't know the context
behind what you wanna do."
- I love that.
- "Just snap out of it and go do."
- That's exactly right.
And the point I was trying
to make to you is like...
- Oh and it got bigger
and better since then.
- Make sense.
And the point is
and also look at why I said that
because I'm self-aware of
what would make me happy.
Dude, if I buy the New York Jets,
people are gonna shit their pants.
Like it's gonna be fuckin'...
Like people are gonna loose...
Do you know how many peole will go on...
Like if I buy the New York Jets,
the amount of people that will go on to do
incredible things will be extraordinary
'cause I'm one of the first humans,
because of technology,
not because I'm special,
this is what made Mohammad
Ali special, right?
He was calling his shots
and he used television,
I will be one...
when I buy the Jets in 27 years,
there will be 35 years
of propaganda at scale
that I told you I was going to.
It'll just be overwhelming.
- And you know what?
Still people will shit on you
and sit there and say,
"Yeah, but for every person
"that called that they
were gonna do it, I mean,
"everyone goes on social media
"and calls their shots."
- Yeah listen
and I feel bad for those people.
Like, if you live a life of cynicism,
there's almost nothing that...
The two things that are
most unattractive to me are
hypocrisy and cynicism.
There just not attractive,
not that everybody has a little,
like I have, I was cynical to Tom Brady,
I'm still tryin' to figure out how to
stay cynical to Tom Brady
in the face of data.
So I get it, you know what I mean?
But I'm willin' to do that
in sports, not real life.
Does that make sense?
Like in sports...
- Well that's your escapism.
You don't wanna go an...
- I hate Paul Pierce,
but do I really?
I don't hate anybody.
- Tom Brady wants VeynerTalent to rep him.
Would you do it?
- Probably not.
And by the way,
and this is why I say that,
when Steve Ross bought
a piece of VeynerMedia,
he offered me a percentage
of the Dolphins.
I can walk around earth right now
and you know how that is,
people don't own full percentages,
and like, I'm loud
and people think it's
bigger than it was, right.
Like three points, one point.
Like, you know what I mean?
Six fuckin' years ago I
could be walkin' around,
the last seven years being like,
you know, part NFL owner,
I could say it.
- Can you count on the Jets?
- Mean I could of.
'cause the owner of the Browns, I think,
owned a piece of the Steelers.
I could of.
I just hate the fuckin' Dolphins, bro.
I'm a Jets fan.
- Well, it's gonna be
a sad day for all of us
when you actually do buy the Jets.
- I agree.
- And this whole thing ends.
Gary, thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
- Thank you brother.
You do a good job.
Finally a place where
you don't have to hear
(bleep)
As many as you know,
if you're watching this,
I've got a Jersey potty mouth.
I grew up in Jersey in the 80's
and it's the way I communicate.
When I first started making
content in the business world,
I cursed in the mid 2000's
and it was stunningly unacceptable
and probably bothered a lot of people.
As time moved on and our culture moved on,
a major percentage of people became okay
with some of the colorful language.
However, a big percentage is not everyone.
And more importantly,
deploying empathy and
caring about the...audience,
is ultimately the only
thing I truly believe in.
I don't wanna change who I am
and nor will I ever
because at the end of the day
I want to put my head on my pillow
and I wanna be happy.
However, I also don't expect people
to conform into me,
I have to conform into them
because ultimately they're the audience.
For that reason,
I'm super excited about
having a curs-free channel.
So many of you understand that my themes
actually can help so many people
that maybe don't like
the colorful language,
but I don't want that to
be a part of the reason
that they can't consume the macro-message,
the real meaning
and I surely don't want anybody to fold
or conform into me.
This is an incredibly
important chapter in my career
and unbelievably exciting channel for me
and I hope you enjoy it for the
rational behind its creation.